the raider season doesn't start until
this fall but if you're looking for a
fan experience with some great food well
you're in luck
mercedes martinez is at the end resort
showing us around the new raiders
tavern and grill on raiders game day
they say
just win baby but today it is just eat
baby we are here at the brand new
raiders tavern and grill at the m resort
hotel and casino and as you can see
this is the newest member of the raiders
family a beautiful
open space that is ready for you to come
visit
whether it's nfl season or not we've got
the raider image store so you can pick
up your merchandise but let's talk about
the real star
of the show the drinks and the food and
hussein the general manager is joining
me who's saying tell us
what you have going on in this space
it's absolutely gorgeous well i
appreciate that
you know we are very excited to partner
with the raiders in general but one of
the milestone
capstone projects of this relationship
is really the raiders bar and grill
with exposed tap lines a modelo themed
bar a roomy martin themed bar
a private roomy martin dining room
exposed keg lines terminating and
floating taps in the restaurant
we really think this ups our game at the
resort from a food and beverage
standpoint yes
it really does and you saw those tap
lines going there let's talk about some
of the cocktails you have
here we are at the modelo bar and these
look
like a meal in itself tell us a little
bit about it you know one thing we
really wanted to do is with uh
micheladas and
a lot of bloody mary's have become
extremely popular over the last few
years
and so we have a build your own bloody
mary bar bill jerome michelada bar
so a customer can come in and take their
bloody mary mitchell out of game to a
whole new level and just win baby with
that oh
we're doing it with this i'll tell you
that and your menu i it
is not just the typical bar food of
course you have your burgers and things
like that
but you've really kicked it up a notch
there yes we absolutely have
uh we have quesadillas we have ribs we
have barbecue
we have a gluten-free menu we have
healthy options you're going to be able
to have a great dinner at this
restaurant and it's not just a sports
car
yeah and it's not just for the nfl
season grand opening you definitely want
to check it out
the raiders tavern and grill we're going
to go do some
sports we are gonna go sit out on the
patio and enjoy some drinks we'll send
it back to you
mercedes those are fully loaded
beverages you got some shrimp in there
enjoy